you Brockman told me that at that Jeff
Triplett wasn't the only head referee
had official to retire exactly it was Ed
Hochuli - now we had not heard that
pretty bummed about it right bummed
hearing that news so you told me that
and then the commercial break head and I
thought to myself okay in the few
minutes that are here let me let me
write an Ed Hochuli retirement letter
and read it out on the air yeah cuz I
had told you we should get ed on right
then and by the way I tried and I'll
tell you in a second how that worked but
we you know I just I typed it up threw
it out and you're and and I said hey
I've got it Rich Eisen show exclusive
and you're like is this real or fake
right and then as soon as I started
reading it and started laughing okay put
it up here so I wrote here's the letter
by the way the letter that we tweeted
out has an Ed Hochuli at the bottom
right hand part of the letter at the
page like he's got his own personal
stationery of himself on it with the
water it's a water and a Hockey League
watermark so I wrote to whom it may
concern football fans everywhere and
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I
thought that's a dead giveaway at the
time many of you have known me as an
official for the National Football
League for the last 28 years but I
started refereeing football at the high
school level in 1973 and that's when I
first discovered my love of combining my
favorite sport with my other favorite
endeavor explaining things in three long
sentences that can really be explained
in one short one so it's been a long
time of roughing and talking and talking
and reffing so after further review I've
decided to finally no longer get up
every day and do what I do in order to
put food on the table keep a roof over
my family and keep doing what I love to
do every day in other words I've decided
to retire which is an instance of taking
three sentences to explain right it's
perfect now if you'll excuse me I have
to head to the gym make sure that my
body remains the temple and of course
make sure the lactic acid buildup gets
addressed by a vigorous freshman
stretching in other words I'm off to do
curls yours and retirement edy oculi SQL
Esquires so we then post it Rich Eisen
show feed exclusive yep
the retirement letter edy Hockley sent
to the NFL and I I guess we have a
reputation of news breaking I might have
one myself would you know a degree from
the Northwestern's middle school
journalism the number of people that
retweeted it and said they thought it
was real is alarming it's the only way
to put it and I guess it's maybe the
difference between you know when you
text somebody and they think that you're
being you know right difficult like no
no that's not my tone like what you you
don't know tone when you read we needed
the eyes in font you needed the eyes in
front the sarcastic font so god bless
him you know how much we love SVP the
best the best they come the man deserves
as many Emmys as you as he can garner in
his career but this is what happened on
this midnight SportsCenter last night
was that hockey Lee a good referee I
legitimately wondered an hour
umpire official expert we actually have
one of those said hockey Lee was
arguably the best ever whatever you
thought of him you certainly knew him
hockey Lee well-known because he had big
arms and because he explained the
administration of the rules in great
detail as he put in his goodbye letter
to the NFL which Rich Eisen to the NFL
Network tweeted out quote explaining
things in three long sentences that can
really be explained in one short one
close quote he certainly looked great
for 67 called two Super Bowls a referee
for 28 years his son's gonna be one of
the guys that replaces him by the way he
closed his letter with I'm off to do
pearl well I mean as you as you said
it's you are guy that has a reputation
work the phone network you got sources
and here's the thing you read it out now
it certainly plays like that thing you
were kind enough to see you ask me to be
a part of the Funny or Die where it's
obviously a spoof in in real time I add
the kind of guy who seems to me to be
self-aware and
that he could have pensions as a goof
and when it was brought up to me in our
meeting hade you see the letter hockey
Leros and I thought oh that's funny and
then later as I'm trying to write this
script I'm not finding it anywhere on
like Google searches or everybody that
and then the producer that Pat is that
goes on eyes and feet so I read you're
feeding them like there it is I see the
quotes at work and I just splat I just
slam it in there on the script and read
it on yes
hashtag Newsom I'm mortified apologies
gonna happen like that but I guess we
tweeted it out like exclusive to do you
know what I should have done to just
really hammer home the point instead of
saying yours and retirement I should
have said yours and sighs smedium
okay that would have made it more
obvious but I think I think the most I
think the most brilliant satire is the
set is the satire that's close enough to
being plausible that you go yeah maybe
right and and so and also this is an
example of just wanting it so
desperately and I guess the kind of
thing where I'm thinking to myself now
like have we have we harmed his
reputation and if so if it's a grievous
defense we will fix it but it seems like
it's I'm sure I can go well it's all
kind of a goof right yeah I hope maybe
my reputation is tarnished that baby I
won't believe like I just cried wolf
I just cried Hockley you know well I
guess but that's entirely on us for not
for not vetting goes on to me that I'm
not able to find this anywhere but there
but again and this is where I'll turn it
and point at you and blame you which
isin when you're a source of you know
information and you got no one else and
it's believable that he's got his own
stationery with himself on it when
there's a watermark of him as believable
as it is that he's gonna go sort out the
lactic acid with the stress
vigorous marginal stretching wouldn't
work the last attacks that black mask's
out as we all are well aware this is
something this is certainly starting
this is it is and it's also not I I mean
I'm legitimately you know you it's it's
honestly it's a great reminder to kids
journalism school out there one source
and then and then verify that's right I
was unable to verify but I just liked it
so much they said it you have my number
you could have called how to saved you
the trouble but then again it all kind
of works you're the best man you're the
best I'm sorry
you're the worst don't don't spook me
like that
I know Mary Scott hang in the blizzard
appreciate the coma appreciate ya snow
rates are picking up enjoy the sunshine
I hate you the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience